that the numbers of the votes recorded
for each candidate is as follows Chris
Adams Liberal Democrats
3780 five-carat Caroline Lewis at field
the Conservative Party candidate 13,000
501 Daniel Harry gun Green Party 1605
Matthew Thomas Pennycook the Labour
Party 34,000
[Applause]
thirty four thousand two hundred and
fifty there were two hundred ballot
papers were rejected
I hereby declare that Matthew Thomas
pinnacle is duly elected the Member of
Parliament for the Greenwich award is
Miss Dickinson
[Applause]
a few pellicle thank you everyone I'm
going to be very brief so that I think
we can achieve what will be a first for
Greenwich which is to leave before
sunrise and I know you'll want to get
home I think this has been announced
astounding election its confounded the
critics it's brought young people out to
vote in record numbers something which
whatever your political view has got to
be a positive thing for the country and
our political system going forward and I
think it's shown what can be done when
we put hope at the center of our
politics rather than fear and division I
just wanted to say a quick few
thank-yous firstly to the returning
officer and all the staff I know how
hard you work and what you've done to
make this count
so quick and efficient and also to the
police who helped ensure that we've had
a safe count and a safe process today in
what has been an exceptionally difficult
month I'd like to thank the other
candidates Chris Caroline and Dan
they've run fantastic campaigns and it's
been a civil and fair campaign I think
you have all done your party's proud and
should be very proud of what you've done
in the past few weeks I'd like to thank
my campaign agent David Gardner my
campaign manager Simon Christie and our
organizer Kirsten Corelli who have
worked themselves to the bone over
recent weeks as have all of the many
volunteers in this hall and hundreds
beyond who come out to help us achieve
this result and lastly most of my family
who haven't had the easiest few weeks
while I've been away
particularly my young son I'm looking
forward to spending time with him I just
want to say as I've said to residents
throughout this campaign it has been the
privilege of my life to represented the
seat where I live where I care
passionately about and I can't wait to
get back on with a job and to continue
to champion the people and the place
that is Greenwich Village thank you very
much
you